[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition du 7 8 journal sur tv 78 nous
sommes le mercredi 17 janvier tout de
suite les titres de l'actualité locale
troisième cérémonie de voeux en commun
hier pour les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine soirée dans un contexte
de menace de disparition des
départements de la petite couronne qui
stopperait définitivement la fusion
entre le 78 92 pierre bédier et patrick
devedjian se sont exprimés sur le sujet
reportage est la grogne des surveillants
pénitentiaires à la maison d'arrêt de
bois d'arcy notamment ils se mobilisent
en soutien à leurs collègues blessés des
agressions abonde un le vieil tarascon
et mont-de-marsan des propositions ont
été faites hier par la ministre de la
justice
on en parle avec le secrétaire local
adjoint de fo pénitentiaire à bois
d'arcy et puis une année 2010 est
historique pour le signer cette le
cinéma situé dans le quartier 17 marée
l'encours a réalisé son meilleur chiffre
d'entrées depuis sa création en 1975 une
programmation variée entre art et essai
et grand public
invité de ce journal luc beaucamp
directeur du ciné 7 une métropole du
grand paris élargie et des départements
de la petite couronne qui
disparaîtraient c'est ce que laissent
entendre les récentes annonces du préfet
de région hier lors de leur voeu commun
à boulogne billancourt yvelines et
hauts-de-seine ont tenu à rappeler leur
opposition au projet un schéma qui
enterrerait définitivement la fusion
voulue par le 92 elle 78 les détails
avec ce sujet de mickaël landreau et
nicolas kirillovitch panneau lumineux
géant pin's pétition à l'entrée le ton
est donné les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine refuse la future
métropole et l'ont fait savoir ce mardi
soir lors de leur cérémonie de voeux
commune ce redécoupage étudié par l'état
vise à créer une métropole de rang
mondial limité à paris à la petite
couronne
exit les autres départements de la
région parisienne dont les yvelines on
nous parle de simplification mais c'est
pour inventer un chaque fois de
nouvelles usines à gaz qui nous
contraignent à des dépenses d'énergie et
d'argent considérables sans jamais
produire le moindre bénéfice mesure
il mesure qui mettra en péril la fusion
entre les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine
un rapprochement opéré depuis 2016 vous
avez une voiture qui est en panne et une
voiture qui marche
vous prenez pas la voiture qui marche
pour réparer la voiture qui est en panne
c'est ce qui est en train de faire le
gouvernement et ça ça m'agace parce que
c'est dramatique
ça nous mettra tous à pied là où il
faudrait qu'on monte dans une voiture
qui est celle de la croissance dans leur
sillage les présidents des cinq autres
départements d'île de france ont pris la
parole au pupitre ou via des vidéos pour
dénoncer ce futur redécoupage le
socialiste le communiste
l'homme de droite tous ceux gens sont
ensemble sont d'accord il faut
décentraliser parce que un service
public qui fonctionne c'est un service
qui est à proximité des besoins des
usagers pour la république en marche le
scénario n'est pas encore tranchée
l'elysée devrait communiquer dans les
prochaines semaines sur le nouveau
statut de cette métropole
tout dépend des compétences qui seront
affectés aussi aux différentes entités
je pense en tout cas ce qui est attendu
c'est plus d'efficacité et plus de
simplicité parce qu'aujourd'hui nos
concitoyens et sa pas forcément qu'elle
est l'entité pertinente pour quelles
actions à mener pour apaiser les
tensions la soirée s'est clôturée par
des concerts de musique classique la
chanson devrait être différent dans les
prochains jours sur la scène politique
régionale le 31 janvier les sept
présidents de départements se
rassembleront de nouveau à boulogne
billancourt pour défendre une métropole
régionale
autre actualité sur le gril le
calendrier du grand paris express et
donc de la ligne 18 ne sera pas tenue à
nancy hier de la ministre des transports
elisabeth bornes lors d'un débat au
sénat pour la ligne 18 une arrivée était
prévue en 2024 sur le plateau de saclay
puise en 2030 à versailles elisabeth
borne n'a pas remis en question la le
tracé globale du grand paris express
mais estime que les délais ne sont pas
réalistes en raison à des dérapages
financiers du projet coût estimé à 22 6
milliards d'euros en 2013 qui est passé
aujourd'hui à plus de 38 et milliards
d'euros on écoute son intervention
ce projet est crucial pour la région
parisienne
et donc il sera mené à son terme le
schéma d'ensemble n'est pas remis en
cause
il n'est pas question de modifier le
schéma global de ce réseau du grand
paris des délais très ambitieux ont été
annoncées des délais dont je ne pense
pas qu'on puisse dire qu'ils sont
réalistes
quand on voit la complexité quand on
voit la complexité de construire 200 km
de métro automatique en souterrain
largement dans le sol très compliquée du
bassin parisien
le gouvernement qui devrait présenter
dans les prochaines semaines un
calendrier recalés du grand paris
express
un projet global de 200 ha kilomètres de
voies et 68e nouvelle gare de métro en
ile-de-france est la colère monte chez
les surveillants pénitentiaires après de
nombreuses agressions trois gardiens
blessés à vendin-le-vieil jeudi dans le
pas de calais par un détenu radicalisé
au moment de sortir de sa cellule pour
téléphoner un autre détenu s'en est pris
lundi à cet agent à la prison de
mont-de-marsan dans les landes hier une
surveillante de tarascon dans les
bouches du rhône a été frappé par un
prisonnier et depuis plusieurs jours la
mobilisation est forte dans les prisons
à l'appel de plusieurs syndicats
avec moi sur ce plateau david secrétaire
local adjoint de fo pénitentiaire à bois
d'arcy bonsoir bonsoir à des débrayages
se sont produits à la maison d'arrêt
yveline oise depuis vendredi plusieurs
débrayages déjà cran quand on est
surveillant pénitentiaire que l'on voit
là la violence de ces attaques des
collègues qui sont blessés hospitalisés
qui risquent leur vie qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que ça vous fait ça nous fait
mal parce que vis-à-vis de notre
hiérarchie une bonne direction on n'est
pas reconnue même au sein du ministre la
ministre mme belloubet s'est déplacé à
vendin-le-vieil sain sans aucune
proposition elle ressortie de après près
de trois heures de
deux débats avec la direction ou de
concertation avec les agents sans aucune
proposition
elle a juste dit qu'ils reviendraient
nous voir dans deux mois mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas suffisant
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui on est amené à
gérer des détenus de plus en plus
violents voire radicaliser ou en cours
de radicalisation pour certains et
malheureusement on n'a pas les moyens on
n'a pas les moyens matériels on n'a pas
les moyens humains pour ingérer ces
détenus sûr que c'est très compliqué
pour nous de faire face à ces actes
violences faut savoir que dans notre
administration et dans nos détention la
violence est quotidien que ce soit des
insultes des menaces ou des violences
physiques
vous avez dit encore il ya quelques
jours à mont de marsan il ya sept agents
qui ont été blessé assez gravement
hier ça a été à tarascon ii mais ça peut
arriver à tout à fait si on relocalise
sur bois d'arcy on est dans un contexte
où on parle souvent de surpopulation des
prisons des maisons d'un verre un taux
d'occupation parfois 200 % qu'en est-il
la sueur sur bois d'arcy
on est quasiment 2 5% c'est à dire qu'on
est à peu près à 1000 détenus pour 560
places
donc c'est avec le même nombre de
surveillants qui a des années voilà
c'est très difficile pour nous pour pour
gérer au quotidien
il faut gérer des mouvements pour aller
à l'infirmerie des mouvements parloir
des activités et le surveillant l'heure
d'aujourd'hui il est débordé il peut
plus gérer un étage comme il devrait
gérer une unité si on revient sur la
mobilisation à bois d'arcy plusieurs
mobilisations depuis vendredi c'est ça
des débrayages tout à fait soit des
débrayages sont des blocages
d'activité des blocages d'extraction ou
autres afin de montrer au plan national
notre mécontentement
c'est une mobilisation du cou qui
impacte directement la journée vendredi
quand on s'était rencontré sur place à à
bois d'arcy vous aviez retardé l'appel
de 15 minutes ce qui retarde toute la
journée finalement après sur sur la
maison d'arrêt tout à fait le but
premier de ce débrayage c'est
sensibiliser au maximum les agents oui
c'est être en soutien avec nos collègues
de vendin qui avait été agressé afin de
leur montrer qu'on n'est pas à l'abri de
ça ça nous arrive les insultes les
menaces mais les coûts là ça peut
arriver ça arrive malheureusement trop
souvent vous lisiez un taux d'occupation
sur bois d'arcy qui arrive qui frôle
quasiment les 200% du coup sur les
revendications on imagine une des
premières revendications c'est de
demander davantage de moyens humains
tout à fait il faut augmenter le
recrutement des surveillants ou de
l'encadrement
il faut des moyens humains beaucoup plus
important il faut des moyens matériels
et il faut éventuellement une
normalisation stato rial c'est à dire
qu'il faut passer par des réformes
il faut que madame la ministre entend de
ce message qui est fort quand même de la
part de l'administration pénitentiaire
alors vous évoquiez justement ce
déplacement hier à la prison de
vendin-le-vieil de la ministre de la
justice nicole belloubet alors des
propositions qui n'ont pas forcément
reçu un écho auprès auprès des syndicats
en tout cas elle a fait dix propositions
elle a évoqué notamment plus de moyens
humains on en a parlé l'étude du
transfert de certains détenus des
formations six plus grandes pour pour
les surveillants du nouveau matériel de
sécurité c'est ses troupes eux
vous en voulez vous en voulez encore
plus c'est qu'elles sont et où
finalement les autres revendications
au delà des moyens humains disons
qu'elle a fait des propositions pour
wendel viennent mais l'a pas fait des
propositions au plan national front
national c'est sûr que wendel vielle
avait besoin de plus de moyens matériels
de plus de moyens humains
mais ça il ya des années que les ordis
les organisations syndicales le dénonce
à vendin après sur le plat national elle
a fait aucune proposition
donc nous ce qu'on demande c'est le
recrutement massif mike de personnel de
surveillance
c'est une revalorisation de notre
carrière de notre plan de carrière c'est
des moyens matériels beaucoup plus
important ça passe éventuellement par
l'armement
aujourd'hui on a sifflé une paire de
clés c'est pas avec ça qu'on peut
défendre face à des tenues qui
radicalise et une autre revendication
dont vous ne parliez vendredi c'était
aussi de prévoir des centres détention
spécialisé pour les détenus radicaliser
il faut ouvrir des établissements
spécialisés
c'est à dire que des détenus reydel
radicaliser dans les malles isolement
mais on n'écarte isolement qui est pas
extensible nécessaire que le de nos
quartiers isolement il regorge de
détenus radicaliser il faut des
établissements spécifiques pour ces
détenus le temps là la mobilisation va
se poursuivre du coup sûr sur bois
d'arcy sur bois d'arcy et poursuit par
exemple vendredi on organise le nouveau
blocage est un cop la nationale en
europe ont eu accès à une ouverture de
la part de madame la ministre ou hot on
continuera nos revendications alors il
nous reste peu moins de deux minutes est
un autre sujet que je voulais aborder
avec vous un sujet qui a été un peu
éclipsé par cette actualité de
mobilisation dit ciel automne 2020 la
quasi-totalité des cellules sera équipé
d'un téléphone fixe une mesure voulue
par le ministère de la justice
elle est détenue pourrait appeler
jusqu'à quatre numéros vérifiez
également appelé des associations des
coûts' et c'est une mesure pour vous qui
pourrait apaiser le climat en prison où
ça va compliquer les choses selon vous
pour l'organisation syndicale que je
représente c'est quand même un peu une
utopie parce que en 2017 on est à plus
de 33000 téléphones portables saisis
oui pour amir aux 69 mille personnes
détenues
donc je pense pas que les téléphones en
cellule puisse faire baisser les
chiffres de saisies ou puisse faire
baisser le climat de violence
il faut juste savoir que par exemple sur
bonheur si on a des cabines
téléphoniques qu'ils soient accessibles
sur les sur les coursives donc sur la
sur les couloirs et c'est très rare les
personnes détenues qui accèdent à la
cabine téléphonique d'accord voilà il ya
énormément de portable saisi tous les
jours de plus en plus à jour de ses
idées portable ce soit par projection
que ce soit dans les cellules donc je
pense que c'est quand même une utopie de
vouloir mettre des portables en cellule
concrètement ça ça changerait pas les
choses au quotidien pour vous déjà les
communications faut sauver les
communications téléphoniques sont trop
cher on est entre 50 et 80 centimes la
minute
alors qu'aujourd'hui avec 5 euros un
forfait illimité donc pourquoi s'en
priver après il faut comprendre aussi
que c'est pas évident pour une personne
détenue peut-être de téléphoner de
vendre ses autres co détenu dans une
cellule
ça sera des sociétés extérieures qui
vont ils gérer ses téléphones donc il y
aura pas une rapidité une réaction
vis-à-vis de la population pénale en cas
de panne en cas de dégradation watts et
c'est une mesure on le rappelle qui est
prévue d'ici à 2020 qui évolue par le
ministère la justice merci david
secrétaire local adjoint du syndicat fo
pénitentiaire à la maison d'arrêt de
bois d'arcy on va suivre la suite de la
mobilisation des agents sur bois d'arcy
à des changements et ses légions à
partir du 1er janvier le stationnement
par exemple est devenue une compétence
des communes désormais ce sont elles qui
fixe les tarifs des amendes c'est ce
qu'on appelle des forfaits poste
stationnement et dans les yvelines en
cas de non paiement à l'horodateur les
automobilistes devront débourser de 15 à
35 euros selon les villes est le point
avec camille lambert ne dites plus pv
mais fps forfait poste stationnement
c'est une nouveauté de cette rentrée
2010 8 ce sont les villes qui fixe elle
même les prix de ces nouvelles amendes
de stationnement dans les yvelines le
tarif s'étend de 15 à 35 euros à
guyancourt en cas d'absence de tickets
derrière le pare brise
il faudra payer 25 euros le but c'est
pas de d'obérer le pouvoir d'achat des
aiguilles en courtois et c'est vraiment
qu'on est vraiment un
un turnover parce qu'on est sur des
zones où il ya quand même certaines
tensions où les gens bougent peu et les
aigles et des résidents sont pas mal
plein jeu donc on a eu quelques
remontées quand même à proximité de la
gare donc ça attire beaucoup de monde
donc voilà l'idée c'était effectivement
d'avoir un montant qu'ils soient
suffisamment dissuasif mais non plus
qu'il n'est pas qu'ils ne sont pas du
matraquage une augmentation pour gagner
en efficacité
d'autres communes ont fait ce choix
comme montigny le bretonneux passait à
25 euros
trapel en cours à 35 euros dans
certaines zones plaisir maintient les 17
euros de l'ancien amendes pour les
automobilistes cette mesure est
dissuasive 17 euros déjà c'est pas mal
et en plus maintenant maintenance et
24/25 donc maintenant j'ai encore tu en
principe je paye su toujours relevé vaut
mieux payés que de prendre une prune
jacques moins cher c'est vrai que ça
fait pas mal de 50 centimes pour de
moins de 10 minutes
quand on fait juste un aller retour
voilà après bon si ça peut éviter de
payer 25 euros c'est quand même mieux
autre évolution le paiement de l'amendé
t'ajuster en fonction du dépassement de
leurs limites de stationnement si vous
avez déjà payé 10 euros ils seront donc
déduits et si la police municipale
s'occupe toujours du contrôle à
guyancourt
les communes pourront aussi faire appel
à des sociétés privées depuis 1952 il
est le seul établissement de l'union
européenne constitué uniquement de
sections internationales le lycée
international de saint germain en laye
avait être complètement réhabilité la
première pierre symbolique de ce
chantier qui a démarré il ya quelques
mois a été posée ce matin à le chantier
va durer au total 36 mois premières
livraisons dès février 2019
une rénovation et extension chiffré à 70
millions d'euros financés par les
yvelines et la région ile-de-france
propos recueillis par maxime le maine
pour le conseil départemental des élus
cette réhabilitation est essentielle
pour la vie quotidienne de
l'établissement parce que tout
simplement nous étions très à l'étroit
dans nos locaux des locaux qui n'ont pas
grandi pendant que la population
scolaire augmente et donc il nous
fallait absolument des bâtiments
supplémentaires et des salles de classe
supplémentaires c'est ce que va nous
amener ce projet de rénovation et
d'extension puisqu'on va avoir une
vingtaine de salles supplémentaires à
plus de 109 mille spectateurs en 2010
le ciné c'est des longs cours a battu
ses records d'affluence depuis sa
création en 1975 dans le quartier 17
marée elancourt bonsoir lubbock ans
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur du ciné
700 9000 spectateurs en 2010 7,3 sur nos
semis 0 0 2 0 0 2 c'est très précis
voilà un peu plus de sang a pu lutter
spectateurs 3000 entrées plus par
rapport à 2000 16 points un cinéma de
quartier qui compte sont le rappel trois
salles
c'est quelque chose d'énorme à eux mais
on est très très content d'ailleurs on
remercie jeu j'en profite je profite
d'être sur ce plateau pour remercier à
la fois les spectateurs qui nous sont
extrêmement fidèle et ça c'est très
agréable parce qu'on travaille tous les
jours pour eux pour les accueillir il y
à norma s'ils viennent de plus en plus
nombreux dans une fréquentation
nationale qui est plutôt en baisse en
2010 êtes-vous fait quasiment 3% de plus
oui donc c'est super forme et ainsi
aussi mon équipe bien sûr ceux qui sans
rien de tout cela ne serait possible
et puis les élus aussi qui nous
soutiennent et qui maintiennent la
société mas on vit dans ce quartier 17
mars qui est très important à mon avis
donc on est très content c'est la
meilleure année comme vous l'avez dit
depuis l'ouverture du cinéma on a
explosé entre notre guillemets tous nos
records
je savais me descendre on dépasserait la
dernière qui était déjà une année de
records mais déjà dès décembre le serial
hors jeu savait pas dans quelle mesure
on irait frisottés avec les 110 milles
bond est pas très loin d'être un
objectif d'ailleurs pour 2018 et
souhaitons le ce que tous redoutaient
alors en dix ans le ciné 7 a progressé
de presque trente mille spectateurs il y
a eu des travaux d'agrandissement sept
ans en 2012 on va peut-être y revenir
tout à l'heure
vous en avez évoqué quelques mots sa
récompense aussi travail d'une équipe il
ya cinq salariés ou au ciné cette en
fait plus précisément en et 6 pour face
à 6 avec moi voilà donc oui bah c'est
c'est un travail passionnant en même
temps parce que vous imaginez une équipe
de six personnes mais ça veut dire
polyvalence pour tout le monde
il faut que tout le monde sache ans et
une projection il faut que tout le monde
sache à un geste est un film il faut que
tout le monde sache qu'au bon
tactiquement ça se passe
faire une caisse reccueillir des
spectateurs nettoyer les salles entre
les séances voilà la vie d'un cinéma
lambda quoi donc
on est soudés on c'est vrai que il faut
pas qu'il y en ait deux qu'ils soient
malades en même temps par exemple ou
deux qui partent en vacances en même
temps pendant les petites vacances
scolaires auraient été puisqu'on est
ouvert je le rappelle 52 semaines par an
sept jours sur sept on remplit une
mission qui nous a été comment dirais-je
qui a été définie par les élus oui quand
ils ont comme on dirait je écrit les
statuts de la sem qui est aussi une
mission de service public donc on a une
société d'économie mixte comme son nom
l'indiqué donc on doit tendre vers un
objectif d'équilibré financier ce qu'on
essaye de faire le plus possible en tout
cas est aussi remplir des missions de
service public autour de l'action
culturelle de l'animation dans la ville
de l'éducation à l'image et d'autres
alors ici on expliquer cette année de
succès déjà sur les sorties ciné il faut
le dire l'année a été riche en contenu
oui on l'a très bien fini en plus avec
star wars qu'on a eu la chance d'avoir
ça je j'assiste là dessus parce que
c'est très important
il faut que la petite exploitation en
france pour les petites exploitations
assez pour être un peu technique c'est
un cinéma qui a trois salles maximum il
faut absolument que la petite
exploitation en france
et ça il faut que les distributeurs nous
aident et accès aux films en sortie
nationale
on sait très bien que notamment pour les
blockbusters ces gros films là il faut
les avoir très vite - parce que si on
les a pas très vite si on les a trois
semaines quatre semaines après et 20 les
gens déjà été les voir ailleurs dans les
multiplexes ou dans d'autres dans
d'autres cinémas relevant de la moyenne
exploitation c'est à dire entre 3 et 8
salles c'est important les ordres d la
sorte il faut les avoir il faut les
avoir tout de suite il faut les capter
tout de suite les gens les attendent les
gens veulent les voir le public à rester
il est plus patient oui il est plus prêt
à attendre un petit peu
à partir du moment où on lui donne les
bonnes informations donc ça veut dire
qu'aussi dans nos petites exploitations
il faut qu'on communique
de mieux en mieux de plus en plus et de
mieux en mieux donc évidemment internet
etc utilisent les réseaux sociaux on
fait tout ce qu'on peut blockbuster vous
en avez parlé et la récession aussi on
dira l'autre facette du ciné 7 c'est
important il ya des lunes programmation
art et essai d aussi des festivals tout
au long de l'année qui sont proposés au
ciné c'est en fait plein de choses c'est
vrai que depuis qu'on a rouvert on est
très heureux parce que on a pu mettre en
place alors on a un lieu qui est à
l'image de ce qu'on voulait qu'il soit
c'est à dire qu'il est à tout le monde
nous le dit il est chaleureux et
convivial il est à taille humaine
on a une politique tarifaire encore une
fois soutenus par les élus de la ville
et de est de 51,10 vide et la ville de
maurepas aussi puisque la vie devant pas
être aussi actionnaire
du ciné 7 qui comme on dirait qu'ils
répondent à une attente ce lieu répond à
une vraie attente des spectateurs et
l'attachement aussi on les atteint 1975
et on en revient la création du quartier
17 mars
c'est aussi 1075 on était en plein dans
la création ce qu'on appelait à l'époque
la ville nouvelle de cinq ans et neuf
premiers jeux d'identité voilà c'est pas
le premier cinéma de 50 ans noël il je
crois savoir que c'est le grenier à sel
qui est le premier signal rakotonirina
trappe qui est le plus ancien mais nous
on doit pas être loin derrière et c'est
vrai que ceux-ci débat il a vécu plein
de choses plein aventure il avec une
aventure en étant gérée de façon
purement commercial commercial au départ
ensuite il a été repris par un
triumvirat le libraire et rijkaard un
associé entre jeunes beaux mais jean
jacques chesnais qui l'ont géré pendant
quelques années avec avec des choses
intéressantes ils ont fait des choses
très intéressantes mais il n'avait pas
de quoi se payer où nombre d'entre elles
qui étaient réalisés à l'époque dense et
on était en pleine chute de la
fréquentation aussi donc la ville a
repris en 93 beaucoup nous on est arrivé
à ce moment là et on a relancé les
choses on a travaillé dans un lieu qui
commençait à vieillir quand même et ça
sentait on savait qu'il fallait qu'on
fasse quelque chose et des travaux en
2012 où on a eu l'arrivée d'une
troisième salle des logis sont là quatre
canaux notamment absolue on est au top
aujourd'hui ça c'est grâce à saint
quentin en yvelines parce qu'ils nous
ont fait eux qui ont financé la plus
grosse partie des travaux même si la
scène a mis au bout mais oui on est au
top
on a un équipement tout le monde nous le
dit qui encore une fois chaleureux bon
j'ai déjà dit qu'ils confortable région
de la place au port pour leurs jambes on
n'a pas retourné à préférer perdre des
rangs plutôt que d'entasser les gens
comme dans une boîte quoi et le reste on
peut lui souhaiter en 2018 aux autres si
l'on vit
un bel avenir et puis au regard du
paysage cinématographique qui comme vous
le savez va changer qu'on résiste on
reste là que les gens continuent à nous
soutenir continuent à venir nous voir et
on sera toujours très heureux de les
accueillir et aux projets pour pouvez
d'ailleurs suivre l'actualité du ciné 7
sa programmation via sa page facebook
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci le
beau quand à d'avoir été avec un cv
directeur du ciné 7 à elancourt la
culture toujours direction montigny le
bretonneux ou le conservatoire a pour
habitude de nous présenter des artistes
lors d'expositions cette fois ci ce sont
des élèves qui sont la mise à l'honneur
jusqu'au 26 janvier
peinture volume montrent différents
travaux réalisés lors des cours pour
confirmer à camille lambert à la voix
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images
un exercice plus difficile qu'il n'y
paraît ces jarres sont construites
d'après un savoir-faire africains les
dix élèves du cours céramiques poteries
du conservatoire des arts de montigny le
bretonneux font découvrir leurs
techniques les gros boudin qui sont
posés les uns sur les autres et qui sont
après est tiré voilà pour être plus fins
et une technique assez rapide et c'est
vrai qu'en afrique on a une chaleur qui
permet de pouvoir monter assez
rapidement nous ici on a une hydrométrie
et une température qui qui varie suivant
les cuissons suivant le temps donc on
est obligé de le faire évoluer lentement
mais c'est une technique qui permet pas
de grandes jarres la terre quand on n'y
touche c'est c'est comme une vibration
dans tout le corps c'est vrai on met
lass et c'est une terre gré chamottée
qui abîment un peu les doigts
présent au coeur de l'exposition les
visiteurs pourront les rencontrer tous
les mardis peinture volume met à
l'honneur les artistes de demain
nous aspirons d'une
d'un photographe hollandaise daniel van
zadelhoff qui travaille beaucoup sur les
clairs obscurs et donc j'ai pris ce
travail comme exemple c'est pour une
fois une forme de deux confirmations et
d'encouragement pas parce qu'ils sont en
train de faire est de mettre en pratique
un peu ce qu'ils apprennent rigueur
créativité et détermination des qualités
que chacun peut développer lors des
cours du conservatoire des arts
les inscriptions sont ouvertes à tous un
mot de sport avant de clore ce journal
plus précisément du à badminton avec les
volants d'elancourt le club organisait
ce week-end son 17e tournoi de doubles
au palais à des sports de la ville un
événement qui a réuni plus de 350
participants venus de 89 clubs français
mickaël millero et nicolas landry on
puisse ont pu suivre une paire mixte le
dimanche
[Musique]
les services l'on serait logique
échanges stratégiques à la pause entre
magali burkel et pas comme richard
l'objectif de ces deux badistes
remporter ce 17e tournoi de double
organisé ce dimanche 14 janvier par les
volants d'elancourt
pour cela les sportifs licenciés à saint
quentin en yvelines ont une stratégie ça
qu'il soit gaucher c'est un atout le
fait qu'il soit gaucher ça perturbe à
pau les adversaires donc sur mon coup
droit du tout ce que je peux attaquer
plus facilement
on va essayer de jouer là dessus les
deux joueurs doivent également apprendre
à jouer en double et surtout à
communiquer pour remporter la victoire
face aux 350 concurrents présents ce
jour là
[Musique]
pas facile pour deux joueurs
spécialistes du simple le jeu en double
homme va vite c'est plus rapide c'est
plus du jeu tendu le mythe vu que la
fille est devant et que le garçon est
derrière c'est celui de la tacc placé en
fait l'homme qui est derrière il va
mettre en retard son adversaire homme et
il va faire qui va faire un volant un
peu ras terre et la fille qui au filet
mavs a pu tenir le point du dossier pour
la deuxième fois seulement les deux
joueurs sont considérés comme les
favoris du tournoi par les organisateurs
dès les premiers matches de la journée
va gagner pas comme mon bon niveau de
badminton ne savent quand ils ont
l'habitude de jouer en mixte avec
d'autres partenaires
ils connaissent les techniques donc
voilà c'est plus facile pour eux qu'à
deux débutants qui vont commencer
évidemment ça va être plus compliqué à
se situer sur le terrain
un pronostic gagnon la paire magali
burkel et pas comme riesch a remporté la
compétition les autres résultats des
catégories sont à retrouver sur le site
internet du club
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal édition
à revoir sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78
excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]